why is nesting or equal to x squared
what would this look like well the first
thing we know is just what I've been
shown is patently right that y equals x
squared will be the boundary right that
sort of point I want you to write that
down
that confident that you can fight the
boundary of inequality by setting it to
the in equation this is the boundary
because it's inclusive because inclusive
I'm actually going to draw our solid
wire rather than Donilon like I did here
so let's draw this guy you okay now you
can see my life here by boundary wine
with X square which I already have label
which is good
you should also label because very
frequently you'll get lots of either the
same graph it divides the coordinate
axes into two halves I suppose you can
call it like an inside and an outside
which part is in the region which parts
satisfies the inequality
any takers here okay so you could
describe the outside how we test this
out now if we remember for I said hey
wherever you can try and test the origin
why do I suggest that by the way but
once you select the origin 0 0 always
easy to something they just make things
really simple in this case you cannot or
you won't get much value out of testing
the origin why not it's white also
boundary so um number one it's true but
that doesn't tell you anything about
which side works okay so it's that mean
to pick a point that's clearly on one
side so what would you like me to fix
fun one
hello 1 0 1 0 this point here just like
I'm just like zero ones also pretty nice
to evaluate monthly way and I also try
and point Vicki's wherever I can't
because good negatives okay so this is
um does it work yeah Indira less than or
equal to 1 squared the answer is yes so
just like before I'm going to
well firstly this guy gets a tick so
he's good which means that it has
everything on the same side of the
boundary as this guy is also me so I'm
going with this outside area here and if
you have a pencil I encourage you to
shave shading with so much better the
previous line and did get confusing like
just yeah some shading is vastly
superior but I cannot say in white bull
market so I'm just doing my best present
moment how much just operation you will
go because what you're trying to do is
draw a picture you can use the picture
to your image and with Quinn's
one-dimensional ones you can manipulate
an inequality like that quite
successfully legally but with two
variables it's not written already okay
now I want to get across to you a bit of
a rule of thumb fear remember when I
said like inside and outside here and
over here I say left and right did you
notice that
but I also provided the equations to you
with why is the subject why is the
subjects you notice that Y is less than
or equal to Y is less than okay if you
see this is holly was writing down off I
show to you if you see why is the
subject and this is there's less than or
greater than okay you can really read
this as above or below these are all
that there so it's going to be below and
this one over here also happens to be a
lot can you see if I switch the
direction of the other body right if I
made this y greater than or equal to x
squared you get every point above the
parabola okay now that we're all sub
we're really hopeful when I give you
this next example but I give a question
first one of those is why let's go
why bless their brain is 2 X plus 1 is
that we said yeah yeah yeah absolutely
that's a great question
so they've quickly draw that and I'll
show you how to use this rule of thumb
negative 2x plus 1 like so I am going to
suggest based on this rule of thumb be
above maintenance we call these
heuristics all right I'm going to
suggest it beneath beneath this line
which is this part of if you can we test
it out to the origin satisfy this area
that I've shaded it does doesn't it
0 is less than 1 it does work but it
starts to get trickier we consider do
you remember we how to look at limits
and continuity
you remember continuity okay you're
going to have to be a little careful
with this one I want you to try this guy
now I've given you some tools so far the
pressure of you taking years first put
in that boundary and then think okay am
I on this side or this side I want you
to have a go at this question see if you
can use those tools in the same way
how'd it go see what you come up with I
have begun by taking the same oppression
we've seen so far which is example if
you let me have a region the region is
dispensed in somewhere right there has
to be a boundary and each time I've
noticed that the way to get the boundary
is by setting the inequality to the end
equation so here is y equals 1 or s y
equals 1 on X that's the equation of the
boundary if you have not already please
label B Chris Mader is critical then I
considered I trying to work out okay on
which side am I
however you notice unlike the previous
example there are two branches here
there are two branches so when I say oh
there's like different sections here
well it's not so simple as just saying
there's an up and a down or a method
right or an inside and an outside okay
well the face of it it looks like this
kind of three sections like this one as
it is in between and then
this one right but even that doesn't
tell a whole story I tried to clue you
into this by saying there's also
discontinuity here right where is the
discontinuity what it's at okay now we
tend to usually say determinant isn't
domain so even though it's true there is
a description bit of y equals zero if
all the people say that it just got to
do it x equals zero because if for is
not we have a look at this guy right you
would say this function is continuous
right there breaks you can draw the
whole thing in one go but you would say
oh because it's discontinuities down G
are like you know but we don't care
about that for all X values it's fine
so this x value here x equals zero
you're in trouble so I'm just going to
label here and unjust rate to note that
okay
then at this point I want to think you
can view the same rule of thumb I had
before I don't if the Y is the subject Y
is greater than so that suggests to me
which region should I be looking at when
I look at this one I said it's below all
right and for this one I also said below
and let's know we've got Y is radiant
which suggests above right so let's find
a point that's above and test it out how
about here that's a pretty nice
convenient spot to test I guess the
course would be negative one zero does
this quite satisfy the inequality
negative one zero so that would be the
zero there and this would be 1 or
negative 1 1 or negative 1 of course
being negative 1 is 0 greater than
negative 1 it is and in fact if you put
0 in here and any negative number in
there to notice that does that make
sense they're all fine right are you
going to test the people so therefore as
my rule of thumb predicted up here above
here everything looks good you can tip
if you want to contain yourself but then
this is discontinuing things stop the
world's box working at x equals 0 for
this function so when we have a look
over here again I want to test my
intuition see does this be above this
also what what
point out here contestant 1 1 2 1 2
would be as 1/1 on the line so once is
just going to be a bit of Bob right
does it work is 2 greater than 1 over 1
the answer is it is so therefore I'm
going to get again this section above
it's a bit weird there are not three
sections or two there are in fact four
and they're broken into pathways of
discontinuity and then there's above and
below of both sides of the disk
constituting lamingtons okay I've given
you three examples I'm going to give you
one more and then we're going to set you
to work independently this guy is pretty
important okay now khalaq I'll talk you
out with this one I won't take you to
your own devices go ahead enjoy your set
of axes and from what I've told you for
the batteries so far what can you tell
me about the boundary of this what is it
what kind of shape is it it's a circle
very good so keep quick demo comments
let me draw the circle film or dotted
filled because the battery is included
let's go ahead shut that guy over there
she needs a sex with the corner acts is
a pretty critical spots because the
radius of this circle is 4 so this will
be 4 4 negative 4 negative 4
okay now here's another way you can
figure out you're not going to be able
to use this rules of public speed before
man up about right we really truly are
going to have inside or outside in this
case okay so which one is it x squared
plus y squared has to be greater than or
equal to 16x squared plus y squared has
to be greater than or equal to 60 so
therefore let me give you an example of
a value that would work if x squared
plus y squared will equal to 25
would that set of points satisfy this
inequality
take remove it
do you know where X square plus watch
where it is it's a circle setter origin
radius 5 well if this is true then all
you have to do is substitute here and 25
easy indeed great no no Chris 16 or what
about x squared plus y squared equals 36
if it's also going to work yes in fact
because the greater than or equal to you
can just make this radius as large as
you like so therefore all of these guys
are just circles that go further away
right and you can have searches as far
away as you want
so therefore oh yes here we go I'm going
to get the outside right everywhere out
here all of these guys are all fine okay
yes in evite this of engineering here
can you sub in here
absolutely you can you can do it the
same way we did before 0 squared plus 0
squared is that greater than equal to 16
not last I checked for 0 is not greater
than 16 so therefore the origin is not
part of battery so therefore everything
else is samus's